that we bring in Republican congressman
from Texas Dan khaw Dan always good to
have you with us thank you very much for
being here uh I want to start off with
this exchange between our reporter
Hillary vaugh and John Kirby watch
this people are being given court dates
7 years from now so is he creating a big
problem for another president to have to
figure out if these people are going to
be deported after just working living
maybe having families here for 7 years
again I'm not going to get into
hypothetical cases here on day one of
the administration the president put to
Congress a proposal for immigration
reform he has said in recent days he's
willing to have a serious discussion
with members of Congress about
immigration
policy okay Dan uh Congressman you said
he put something out there on day one so
he did his part what he say to that not
sure what he's talking about what he did
on day one was reverse all the Trump era
policies that were actually fixing the
Border namely remain in Mexico policy
this is a really simple this is a really
simple equation you say you have a
higher than likely shot of being sent
back to Mexico and awaiting your
adjudication there then people won't
come so yes he did propose something on
day one but it was reversing the
policies that actually worked you don't
really need a whole lot of new
immigration law to get this border to
work you just have to enforce what's
there you know to the extent that we are
proposing different immigration law
changes like we have in hr2 earlier this
year um that's really cleaning things up
that's closing loopholes so that a
president like President Biden can't
just go around Loop and and create these
loopholes whether it's using the Asylum
process or this Mass parole program that
he's done and these notices do appear I
mean that's even if they do appear
forget hypotheticals you don't need to
talk about hypotheticals most of these
people do not appear period we have the
statistics on that you know you you you
have to have a seismic change in policy
to reverse this
crisis I want to show this video that we
showed on the way into the te's because
it it's one that really sticks with me
Congressman uh we believe this is one of
the Smugglers he he lets they saw down
pieces of our fence right and then he
shrugs and gives a salute and basically
runs back probably to get a whole
another group of people who are likely
paying him uh and the other Smugglers
thousands of dollars to get them through
so a shrug and a salute is what we get
is there a justification for some use of
force for the destruction of our border
wall and illegal trafficking at our
border as president I think you could
absolutely make that justification when
there's somebody right there uh
committing a crime destroying our
property right at the border now but
let's talk broader here you know because
I've introduced legislation to use
military force against the cartels that
guy you see in that video he is
connected to the cartels in in one form
or another the cartels battle each other
for what's called plazas which just
means space next to the Border because
it's so lucrative right they charge
every single one of those people uh some
kind of fee to cross that border there's
there's an entire trafficking process
and the cartels make $ 13 billion dollar
a year by some estimates so it's almost
more than they make drug trafficking so
you can make a pretty good case that
these cartels are a mutual enemy of both
Mexico and the United States and should
be dealt with in a military manner now
they're killing Mexicans on a daily
basis they will they will lure teenage
boys um into a call what they say is a
call center tell them they're going to
get a job offer them a job with the
cartels they deny them and then they
torture and kill them that's what goes
on in Mexico every single day there is
no reason why we shouldn't be using
every every ounce of American Force
along with the Mexican military to deal
with this and that when and when
secretary blinkin goes down Mexico City
in the next few days like they
supposedly are to talk about this those
that's what needs to be on the table
what are we going to do to help you take
your country back and what are you going
to do to stop this Mass migration stop
stop facilitating Mass migration into
our
border yeah I I mean I hear you I don't
think there's any reason for them to
stop this extraordinarily lucrative
business if nobody is going to get in
their way and and all they're going to
do is shrug at us and give us the old
salute she thanks a lot there's another
uh you know multi thousand drop off so
Congressman I thank you very much for
being here uh good to have you with us
today and we wish you a happy holiday
thank you sir Merry Christmas thanks hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else